m
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no es cualquier nariz es una muy muy
especial viene en diferentes tamaños y
muchos colores pero lo que la hace
realmente especial es el poder de
transformación real que tiene
no todo el mundo tiene una nariz como
estas y aunque ustedes también la tienen
aún no la descubren de la forma que lo
he hecho yo no todo el mundo tiene una
dosis de alegría a la mano así que
sencillamente ustedes y yo somos
afortunados esto de hablar en primera
persona siempre me ha parecido un gran
reto y considero que se enseña mejor con
el ejemplo por eso pronto la conocerán a
ella que es la protagonista real de esta
historia siempre fue una persona muy
tímida a tal punto que me daba pena
incluso aún hablar por teléfono quien mi
mamá me hiciera llamar y preguntar por
otras personas era fatal ni eso era
capaz ya se imaginarán cuan cerrada y
tímida era en aquella época de infancia
y la juventud no cambiaba mucho la cosa
soy de pocos amigos y en el colegio no
me permitía tener novio porque mis
padres me enviaban aquí era estudiar y
no a darme las de coqueta y tener novio
esa siempre era mi regla y siempre era
mi respuesta y estoy segura que aunque
mis padres no
estaban contentos con ella en el colegio
decidí que quería estudiar una
ingeniería porque me gustaba la palabra
ingeniero sonaba inteligente divertido y
a un gran reto porque siempre asociamos
estas carreras con las matemáticas y yo
odiaba los números hasta octavo grado
así que descartando opciones elegí
ingeniería industrial en esta alma máter
y ahora soy egresada hago fps en el año
2012 tomaba clases de teatro en un grupo
llamado utopía en el que por causas del
destino conocía el mundo cloud minúsculo
era un clown caleño bastante alto con el
que tomaría un taller intensivo de cloud
el taller era preparar era para preparar
a los dos actores principales de una
obra de teatro y les yo no era uno de
ellos
pero el taller era para todos así que
aprovechamos la oportunidad
y les cuento que me enamoré del cloud no
de minúsculo no me enamoré de la técnica
clown
[Música]
seguramente vieron esta película de
patch adams
interpretada por robin williams pues
bueno es basada en una historia real que
es importante resaltar
el verdadero hunter patch adams en 1971
revolución a los hospitales de eeuu
cuestionando el hecho de que tratar a
los pacientes por el número de cama o
por el nombre de la enfermedad era un
trato insensible por ello y con la
visión de cambiar la competencia y la
avaricia por generosidad y compasión
crea el instituto heads un game para
tratar a los pacientes de forma especial
brindándoles un trato con afecto y con
humor soy claro hospitalario o payaso de
hospital que viene siendo lo mismo desde
hace más de cinco años inicie en este
mundo mágico y de colores con la
fundación doctor mejoría
pero por causas del destino en el 2015
se clausura esta noticia nos cae como un
baldado de agua fría el voluntariado fue
una noticia muy triste
pero los que estamos en la junta
directiva junto con el resto del
voluntariado tomamos la decisión de
secarlos del agua y crear la fundación
especial para seguir llevando a nuestro
impacto social a la ciudad
inicialmente nos reuníamos en algún
parque para realizar nuestros talleres
de formación tiempo después nos cedieron
un espacio en la casa cultural taller de
títeres de colombia pero no cedían era
un porsche allí realizamos nuestros
talleres de formación si se cruzaba con
algún evento de ellos debíamos volver
otra vez al parque y si llovía nos
colocaba en apuros por eso
tomamos la decisión de empezar a buscar
un sitio algo que fuera propio algo
nuestro un local una sede económica y
central y dimos con la sede en la que
estamos actualmente no ha sido un camino
fácil no tenemos patrocinadores
y
los voluntarios damos un aporte mensual
pero no todos los voluntarios podemos
siempre ha sido una tarea difícil
pero dejar de hacer lo que hacemos nunca
ha sido una opción a considerar los días
del voluntariado principalmente son los
sábados y cuando por alguna razón no
puedo asistir la semana realmente se
hace eterna es el día de salir de la
rutina diaria de aprender de reír y de
disfrutar un montón y de compartir
tiempo en familia con mi segunda familia
la fundación hospital el voluntariado es
un hogar de paso que ha graduado a
muchísimos cloud y tiene los brazos
abiertos para recibir a más locos que
crean que la risa lo cura todo y que hay
más al estar en recibir
hola
buenas noches
qué bonito sois todos ustedes y tengo
entre dientes estáis ahí yo no me llamo
a mí me llamaba más el perdón me resfrío
hablo así porque me gusta les gustas
televen entonces y funciona y como dice
el dicho se funciona síguelo haciendo
así que aquí estamos haciéndolo hoy les
quiero contar unos datos muy muy
interesantes pero para ello vamos a
utilizar el apuntador esta cosita que me
ha tomado el pelo nos va a ayudar en
esta ocasión
la votamos no
esta aparentemente soy yo
y los casos las cositas interesantes
eran estas en su libro la indefensión
aprendida
botero oliver y sano la mencionan
diversos beneficios que trae consigo la
risa pero hoy vamos a resaltar 3 la risa
es un ejercicio muscular que moviliza la
mayoría de los músculos del cuerpo
alrededor de unos 400 incluidos algunos
del estómago que únicamente ejercitamos
cuando nos reímos la risa actúa sobre el
dolor favorece el sueño disminuye el
estrés y mejora nuestra calidad de vida
adicionalmente la terapia de la risa es
un instrumento de liberación de energías
que nos permite sentir felicidad plena
debido a que durante el proceso
nuestro organismo libera las hormonas de
la felicidad como lo son la serotonina
la dopamina las endorfinas y la
adrenalina
continuando en el tiempo encontramos que
hay un señor que se llama james lover
que dice que a medida que las
habilidades humanas se perfeccionan
nuestra capacidad de reír disminuye o
sea que a medida que nos hacemos más
viejos también nos hacemos más amargados
es curioso el reviso estudios en niños
de 6 años y encontró que los niños ríen
entre 300 y 400 veces al día un adulto
como nosotros tan solo hace entre 15 y 7
y un adulto mayor ríe menos de 80 veces
así que vamos a tender a crecer y
amargarnos pero yo no quiero o al menos
eso no está en mi plan de vida y espero
que el de vosotros tampoco
i
dice o al menos ella se ríe conmigo y
entonces me acuerdo de que sofía scott
plantea que las neuronas espejo de
nuestro cerebro reacciona y capta la
sonrisa igual que los procesos han visto
que cuando uno y alguien pues tensa el
otro también pues esa funciona igual con
la risa y si alguien sonríe
la otra persona las neuronas le enviaré
el impulso de hacer lo mismo así que es
mucho más rico reír en público porque
todas las personas van a reír un poquito
más
ahora quiero contaros un poquito o algo
de mi primera vez recuerda nuestra
primera vez pero no es esa primera vez
no mi primera vez estaba muerta de miedo
por más preparación que quería tener
cuando llegó el momento de la verdad
me vuelve cobarde
pero ya no había vuelta de hoja y la
función debía continuar empezar y que te
dejen sola con un niño que está triste
está enfermo y me quiero quieren y le
apetece reír pues no es tarea fácil pero
a medida que pasa el tiempo con ellos te
encariñas conoce su historia y el tiempo
se pasa volando son solo diez minutos
pero luego quieres tener muchísimo más
tiempo con ellos en una ocasión
trabajando en urgencias pero no
pediátricas sino de adultos vamos
entrando de sopetón cuando nos damos
cuenta ingresamos al pleno matriarcado
había seis camas todas las mujeres las
acompañantes también eran mujeres las
enfermeras también eran mujeres pero mi
núcleo compañero de juego casualmente
era un niño
oliver
se iba poniendo de todos los colores
porque como había tantas hormonas
femeninas en la habitación lo que todas
queríamos era un striptease
cuando empezamos a decirle a oliver
striptease striptease cambiaba de todos
los colores pero el que más pero miraba
era el rojo él quería que se le abrieron
con la tierra y se lo tragara pero no
había escapatoria la puerta estaba
cerrada y no podía salir pero entrar si
podían el precio que la salvación era un
doctor que entró y le dijo doctor estas
señoras quieren un striptease pero hay
que decirle que en el hospital no se
puede
no le siguió la cuerda más me le dijo
que si se podía porque no si las señoras
querían había que complacerle el pobre
oliver palidecía cuando empezamos pues
oliver empezó a bajarse la bata
pero las señoras se apiadaron del padre
oliver y le dijeron que ya no era
necesario todos estábamos dotadas de la
risa y este es un ejemplo de que a veces
se ríen contigo y a veces se ríen de ti
pues ahí nos veíamos de oliver iba que
bastante que funcionó en otra ocasión
trabajando en el ala de pediatría con
una dupla con la que había una energía
súper alta y muchísima chispa entramos a
una habitación y conectamos con un niño
logramos jugar un rato con él que son
riera bastante e incluso hicimos que se
comiera la cena cuando salimos la mamá
del niño se nos acerca un poquito con
los ojos aguados nos abraza y nos dice
que muchísimas gracias por la visita que
su hijo llevaba algunos días y sonreír y
que no le quería recibir alimento
nosotros nos vamos cuando ya estamos
reunidos todos la señora nos busca nos
llama y nos entrega una caja de pizza
con una gaseosa grande pues nosotras
sorprendidas primero de cómo hizo para
entrar alimentos al hospital porque aún
sigo sin saberlo y fue un gran gesto de
su parte aunque no era necesario con eso
concluimos que lo que estábamos haciendo
pues lo estábamos haciendo bien hay
niños con los que conectas y se ríen con
tan solo verte hay otros que le tienen
miedo a los payasos hay otros que te
quieren abrazar y hay otros que quieren
seguir te a todas las habitaciones hemos
jugado mucho
juegos porque la imaginación es el
límite hemos jugado al pato latas a
desfiles de moda reinados de belleza
bingo y al escondite si en una
habitación pero recuerden que hay
muchísimos escondites allí vemos en las
enfermeras bailando una dinámica que
posiblemente ustedes conocen
hacemos terapias comunitarias y
hospitalarias es decir que visitamos
comunidades vulnerables para llevar un
poquito de esta dosis de humor a los
niños que más nos necesitan
la risa
es algo muy muy bonito además la risa
añade al ave a nuestra expectativa de
vida porque esos segundos que nos
veíamos que es muy poquito tiempo
realmente cinco diez quince sólo son
segundos añade dos días a nuestra
expectativa de vida así que es muy
poquito tiempo y son múltiples los
beneficios que trae sonreír y ahora os
quiero presentar unos amigos ellos son
unos amigos muy muy especiales para mí
cuando los han visto por ahí
distribuidos por el espacio pues ha
llegado el momento de darle uso a ese
elemento que tenéis en el kit vamos a
sacarlo vamos a ubicar qué es eso teoría
y vamos a abrir en caso de emergencias
pues no es muy difícil vamos a sacarlo
sacarlo sacado
listo ya lo tenemos ubicado en la mano
bueno ya hay uno es que se nos haga del
atado ya lo tenemos en la nariz vamos a
apagar la luz y cuando las tengamos
todos debéis estar usándola porque o si
no mis amigos os atacarán en público
porque así son ellos y dios mío yo no
quiero
vamos a ver cuando prende la luz todos
debéis estar con la nariz vale
hay bebés
ayer
a la cuchilla altar a la plata la
cuchilla y la palabra
o sea me manos y todos se me sube a las
rodillas se resume la cintura se
apresura los apristas sabe sobre la
cabeza y
y
y todos saltando vamos a saltar todos
y ahí viene el piojo macho y hay de 28
tierra
ya sabes
sacamos en matar
allí vamos a matar pinos
se lo echamos al compañero
luego vemos la cabeza
y todos saltando
y ahí viene el brujo guacho y llegaron
con el piojo juancho ahora ellos le
querían enseñar a ustedes una canción
que se llama la tasa y seguro con sus
hermanos y con sus hijos la han
escuchado pues bueno vamos a bailar pero
necesitamos que todos se pongan de pie
porque si no hay ningún pájaro yo mismo
abajo y los paramos de pie nos paramos
de pie me han escuchado
bueno vamos a pesar la cuenta de 31
la verdad es que como yo me estaba
moviendo solo en este circuito rojo pues
no me canse
a los cientos yo sé que ustedes hicieron
más ejercicio que yo
como estiramos
aunque
no todos sus ajustes o dorantes sí sí
vamos a pensar a la cuenta 123 soy una
taza una tetera una cuchara y un
cucharón un plato hondo un plato llano
un cuchillito yo tengo soy un salero
azucarero la batidora y una olla express
en su caso hiciera cuchara cuchara
tiempo cuando plato ya no cuchillito
tenedor salero azucarero batidora y hoy
después tres corridas uy si se cansa uno
ahora les quiero decir solamente una
cosa muy importante la nariz es un
instrumento muy muy valioso para
nosotros es la máscara más pequeña del
mundo la que menos cubre pero la que más
descubre es poder es poder dejar el
ridículo atrás y explorar casi cualquier
opción porque casi absolutamente
todo está permitido para un cloud ya
vieron que bailaron la tasa y nos dio
pena
así que hay que hacer un poquito más
seguido el que aún busca nuestro niño
interior y nos lleva al límite saca
nuestra mejor versión y es por eso que
decimos que la nariz es poderosa y
transformadora descongelados gracias
pero más atrás
el ser ese es un muy raro parece
un montón de bichos atados cuando lo veo
me acuerdo de otra y le cuento las patas
y llegó hasta 100
[Música]
[Aplausos]